thank you jerry today is national men's
grooming day and fellas we have a great
spot for you to get your look dialed in
here tell us more it's nick and mikey
and they are from the barber shop cuts
and cocktails which is inside the
cosmopolitan welcome guys how you doing
how's it going brother great before we
get going with the style tell me more
about the barber shop uh so you know the
barbershop we are a full service shop we
do offer anything from you know eyebrow
trims ear waxing to beard trims shaves
hot towel shaves haircuts and all the in
between pretty much you guys do it all
and it's for national grooming day we
want to get a little beer demonstration
today so i think we're going to focus on
um really kind of showing the transition
of the face so really by bringing it in
tighter on the sides leaving it fuller
in the front and then starting with your
point here bringing it up to the jawline
up here
while also giving a volume up top allows
you to have more of a longer look versus
a wider look okay you can do some
trimming right now yeah
and something too with that with someone
like mikey comes in you guys are both
barbers there do you do like a scalp
evaluation to say hey you should have
this kind of cut and this kind of flow
on the beard uh so yes we do um start
out by looking at your civil bone and
then we move right to your um
your
sorry about that
is it trickiest through the beard you
want to keep it shorter down below you
don't want that bushy down there yes
exactly so you want us to keep it right
above right below the uh neckline the
jawline right here and then bring it up
towards the neckline up here and as
you're doing this mikey i love the
texture i don't know i love the texture
of your hair is this the style has
textured kind of coming forward as i'm
yanking on his head is this the look for
the fall uh i think the the mullet is
really in right now but
i'm just kind of in between styles right
now so i shaved my head because i dyed
it and now i'm just trying to figure out
my next look so we've just been doing
this for fun but as far as coloring too
and there's a little color on the top
here what's the color for guys this fall
the color that's in my hair was just an
accident so i didn't it wasn't it was
very stylish it wasn't long enough for
me to be quiet like i want this put in
my hair a lot of guys are going with
like the pinkish colors even some of the
more extreme colors pink purple grays
stuff like that and still seen a lot you
guys are doing great cuts there you get
a compliment you drink when you're
getting a cut too but you also have to
speak easy so you're getting men they're
getting their look styled in but you
also have great performances yeah so our
speakeasy we're open seven days a week
uh sunday
to tuesday we're open at 8pm
and then um
the rest of the week we're open till or
we open at six and we've had last week
we had silk sonic came by it was the
most talked about across the country
yeah i mean you guys are the hot spot
when it comes to styles and also for
performances as well yeah so then we
have on tuesday night we have rockstar
karaoke karaoke night but instead of
like a machine and a dj our house band
plays behind you yes um and then we have
uh wild west wednesdays it's a like a
country rock night um but our house band
they're all like you know musicians that
were successful in their own careers the
all the guys from uh they were all in
life house basketball yeah and so they
have friends that come so we've had
machine gun kelly
uh came by and performed uh sonic as you
said
we had macy gray read a lot of real cool
ones uh kings of leon and zach brown
band came after the cmas and they
actually
sign the list to just get on them for
the karaoke it's huge
i love it i gotta wrap it up real quick
what's the hairstyle for guys this fall
what's the look we showed you a lot of
people are going with the mullet look
that's the mallet with a lot of texture
up top here all right executive producer
selena can i have a mullet no no i can't
have it
i tried we're going to sign him she says
no no mo guys thank you so much for
joining us i appreciate it las vegas now
will be right